so we're gonna start off by just channel
out all the heat that we have that I
mean I like the sound of that I got a
lot of hate in my heart if you got hate
in your heart he's gonna let it out well
let's begin then it's a week we're gonna
kind of snap each new go through the
worst things about YouTube and if we
forget something let us know about it
okay what is what what do you hate about
Charlie Charlie challenge charlie
I don't know what it is I don't know I
don't know what it is now I don't moving
on a reaction video first word boobs
oh that's reply girl sorry
okay reaction videos uh there's this one
guy on YouTube he's getting insane
popularity right now and I've been
paying attention to it uh and he's
literally just watching videos on
YouTube and reacting to it
Wow it he's making a living out of it I
guess that's relatable though because
that's what people do right they watch
youtube videos moving out why are we
whipping I don't know what the whippin
is explained wait I just know and vine
every joke ever is by whipping Nene and
that's Elena I don't know it what does
it Nene is like a but it sounds like a
but you wit will do the nae nae um a
whip is like this it's kind of did you
whip your hair back and forth
now you're just your arm left right
amenda Nene you stick your fist up in
the air and shake your man web hips your
arm fat you shake your arm fat if you
have that you can go ahead and shake
that like you're your old lady wings
yeah I'm shaking mine right now
okay the next oh thank you so much for
everyone watching thanks what is squad
goals squad goals I don't know what that
means let's look it up the best flag
that's what ya lookin up on an urban
dictionary but I think it means people
that need friends they will they have
squad goals like look at all these cool
people together I like these people I
wish I had friends there anything like
the head their squad goals mmm say I
don't have a squad okay final thing on
fleek
I don't know what that means either is
it like you're on porn eyebrows are on
fleek is when no one would ever say to
use my browser you know fantastic
and it'll suck your eyebrows get married
to pluck her eyebrows Ken I mean she she
takes care of me you know Braille for me
and honey yeah a little hairs come out
she gets that she done she's like yeah
that's why you have a girlfriend just
apparently I'm getting old and like I
have like this one hair
the chosen grew in my earlobe a and
she's like snatches out every time they
hurt so bad oh my gosh beautiful
beautiful but it isn't like a website it
should be uh I'm sure it is uh that was
our YouTube honestly our rent what did
we forget anything
leave a comment and we'll well play with
your [ __ ]
play play with your nephew no okay
that was that moving on fantastic
explosion
you